for super quick and easy beef chili add  chopped onions the hot olive oil and  cook until soft then add chopped garlic  a teaspoon of cumin seeds and stir to  release their lovely aromatic flavor  next chili powder turn up the heat and  break beef mince into the pan ground and  seasoned add tomato puree and cook  through  next a glug of spicy Worcestershire  sauce chopped in tomatoes  dried oregano  and a sprinkle of sugar  [Music]  cook frankfurter or Brent worth sausages  bung in a bun and simply topped with a  spicy beef chili  easy and irresistible a dog worth  crossing the street for one nicely  skinned salmon just like a perfect  snake's game because sliders are  bite-sized burgers designed to go in  small buns you don't want to make them  too big